that is for you and Islam religion with
Allah since time began this Malala
hamdulillah assalamu alaykum which is a
greeting of peace peace be unto you this
is a greeting of all the messengers of
God and we're bringing you that same
greeting that same tradition that all
the messengers of God brought they
brought submission and surrender to the
one God which is Islam Islam is not a
new way of life brought by Mohammed
Mohammed is just a last and final
messenger sent to mankind and we're
going to be talking about very serious
issues like we always do here on the
Deen show I was watching the news just
the other day and they were talking
about interviewing a gentleman who was
making close to 750 thousand dollars a
year can you imagine that that's a lot
of money going to the nice fancy Yacht
Club's going golfing taking his wife on
vacations living a nice lavish lifestyle
but now that economy hits and this man
is actually a pizza man right now so
just how God gives it he can take it so
are you really happy for what you have
and what do you do in times of calamity
when all of a sudden and a blink of an
eye you had it now you lost it we want
to get some advice it's a good thing is
that a bad thing can we make a bad
situation turn out to be a good
situation we want some advice and who
best to give it to us then our good
friend shares a dance so you don't want
to go nowhere we're going to be talking
about this very important topic with the
economy and how to get through some of
these tough times when we come back here
on the deanship
Allah there's only one word and Muhammad
is His Messenger
Allah Allah
there's only one God and Jesus was his
messenger no I did that maybe it maybe
it's just to break the ice
assalamu alaikum [ __ ] how are you from -
let's go
alright many people know who you are
some people who don't we cater to a lot
of the non-muslims we're trying to help
them understand the way of life that's
actually for all mankind submission is
surrender not to meet you not to a man
to a monkey but to the crater right
simple not too much philosophy there
right submit yourself to God do what God
wants you to do right Amen that's it yes
so you have memorized which is a miracle
the verbatim Word of God
I don't think there's I'm pretty sure
effect and I'll put out a challenge if
somebody can bring me someone who's
memorized any other scripture like the
way that the crown has been compiled and
preserved and has been memorized and
you're one of those as memorized of
children seven nine years old the rise
the hope this is amazing
so that's one of the miracles but we're
not talking about the miracles and the
evidences to establish that the Quran is
deed the verbatim Word of God we have
other shows for that we're going to be
talking about like when I introduce the
show now the economy people were really
buying houses and enjoying now 30 people
30,000 laid off this month last month
people laid off by the dozens in one
company some people seeing 300 at their
company being laid off another thousand
at this company it just you don't know
if it's coming to you next people are
paranoid people are scared I had
mentioned that there was just an
interview with a gentleman who was
making seven hundred fifty thousand a
year and he now is losing that house
losing that he lost a job now he's a
pizza man
so can this happen to you know us
tomorrow how can the people that are now
going through these things how can they
manage and you know stick it out through
the hard times talk to us give us some
advice shake some the lobster some
Ursula everything is in the control of
the creator of the heavens and years and
he's the most twice and not
happens like dead without a wisdom and
we get to know from the revelation from
the Quran and the Sunnah of the Prophet
Salla Selim
there are two set of means that God
created on the face of earth the
physical means that people know they
work to earn money make money whatever
there is but there's a very important
set of means that only for those who
would trust in the revelation would
understand it and these set of means are
that whoever is in obedience to the
creator of the heavens and earth their
life will be greater than this one and
in the hereafter and there are verses in
the Quran were no peace be upon him he
said to his people Noah Noah know that
if you would turn to Him alone if you
believe in him and worship Him alone if
he become Muslims meaning submitting
yourself to Allah spano Dada alone Allah
Allah Allah will make abundance of your
wealth and he would bring for you
goodness in this earth from the top of
you from the bottom everywhere if you
would turn to him alone and this is also
something mentioned in the Quran and God
also mentioned in the Quran that he
tests people sometime in which he would
give them abundance in wealth when they
are still not aware of the purpose of
their life and he gives them more and
more water below method Korea came at a
militant movement in their Tijeras
Guatemala Mecca meaning its provisions
is coming to it from everywhere
but then they disbelieved in the creator
of the heavens and the earth
so as a result he made them have the
hunger and the suffering and so on and
so forth they were given all of these
means for what purpose for them to use
it for the pleasure of the creator of
the heavens and the earth so everything
is by the wisdom of Allah and Allah is
the most merciful
sometimes he tests his human beings for
them to reflect and to ponder times of
crisis people think and this thinking is
such a beautiful thing and that's what
we call people to think in Islam we
don't call people to just believe the
way it is think and when you look around
you and you see that something is
happening here what almost a note Allah
wants from us he wants from us to turn
to him alone so this is an opportunity
for us to turn to the provider he's the
one that provides and he's the one that
sustains our life the prophets peace be
upon him he said in the authentic hadith
in Allah Allah Allah had revealed to
me that no one will die unless their
provisions are given in fully so as a
result of that he said then do not panic
your provisions will come to you but
only seek that by your obedience to the
creator of the heavens and earth and
also as a result of this obeying the
orders of Allah we know in Islam user is
something that is forbidden and it's not
just forbidden in the Quran forbidden in
the books before but people turned away
from this with the interest and buying
and selling things that is not tangible
things that has no reality to it this is
something that is forbidden in the
religion of Allah and even Allah says in
the Quran that those who deal with
interest that there is a war from Allah
and His Messenger against them that
means they would never have happiness
maybe temporary thing but then after
that it's a real loss as a result of not
abiding by this principle in the
religion of a stand for the benefit of
the human being if you want to buy
something buy something that is tangible
don't buy a piece of paper
don't use loan to abuse one another and
to make interests and everything there
are other forms of making money but not
money making money but things are a
tangible that a person can buy and sell
and we see the wisdom of Allah that was
revealed 1400 years ago we see the
effect of it nowadays when people would
not abide by the the laws that are lost
panatela revealed in the way do you see
now that people are actually coming
trying to stimulate the economy where
they're coming back to saying okay we
have to go towards a lot of the the no
interest loans trying to just get the
people what Islam is saying from the
beginning no interest and now people are
starting to see that that and saying
look pushing towards no interest in
Islam actually loans is a good deed yeah
there are other forms of making money
you see when you talk about charity for
example yeah do we make interest out of
charity
we don't charity is something out of the
goodness of the people yeah the same
thing when it comes to ruin somebody
would say well how can I purchase
something that I want that I don't have
the money for it then comes other ways
of making money buying and selling being
partners whatever there is
but loans it's something that has
nothing to do in the religion of Islam
of making money somebody wants to give a
loan it's a good deed he gets half of
that as
he gave it in charity he only takes what
he give and not something more because
this is abuse as the relationship
between others and it brings what we see
nowadays so it's important at these
times of crisis and this is if we can
get across that to the viewers think and
ponder over what your life is and what's
your future is and turn to the creator
of the heavens and the earth ask him for
guidance see what is the solution in you
turning him alone and when you think
then by the will of Allah if he guide
you he guide you to submit yourself to
the truth read the Quran read the way of
the prophet mohammed salah salem you
would see how simple that life is no one
is worthy of worship except the creator
of the heavens and the earth submit to
him alone and worship Him alone you will
have the happiness in this life and in
the eft tell us how should somebody
should a person who is say a believer
one who believes that there's only one
god that he's submitting to this God
he's striving his best to do the best
that he can do but he's in a situation
where he's seen like three hundred
people just lose their job in his
company
should he be worried or should he just
be like you know what it's all in the
hands of the creator whatever happens
happens how should he feel is it normal
to feel scared right we have our
physical bodies and our state of our
hearts physical body we take the means
in full measures as long as it's
permissible so he would do like
everybody else do his job look for a job
whatever there is but the heart is calm
it's calm why because he's worshiping
the most twice the one that nothing
happens without his wisdom so the human
being should be always pleased with
whatever Allah spano Tala degree for him
there's a purpose for it if you are rich
you are under the test people think that
if you're rich you're okay no you're not
okay unless you fulfill and you pass
this test you have to be grateful to the
creator of the heavens and the earth you
use your wealth in the proper way to
trust and you have to be grateful to him
if you are poor still a test and the
test is be patient seek the help from
the creator of the heavens and the earth
take the means yes the permissible means
but be patient and be pleased with his
destiny and note that this life that's
not the end of it this life is connected
to the hereafter and everybody will be
tested in this life and accordingly
people will be there Affairs will be in
the here
so the heart when it understand this it
becomes in a state of calmness and it
just take the physical means but it
knows that everything is in the hands of
Allah the one that provides for a bird
what is a bird how weak is a bird and
any bird that comes out in the morning
leaves its tree comes back at night with
full stomach who provided for her it's
the creator of the heavens and earth
yeah the prophets are seldom gave us
this example he said now under complete
our Karuna Allah this is the key if you
put your trust in the creator of the
heavens and the earth alone truly and
you take the means of course but your
heart fully trusting the creator of the
heavens and the earth what would happen
to you he would provide for you like he
would provide for the bird comes out in
the morning empty stomach comes back at
night full stomach this bird is not
panicking but it's not staying in one
tree it's going from one tree to the
other taking the means but the heart is
settled and calmed that it would never
come back at night with an empty stomach
it would be provided for because she did
that bird knows that the creator of the
heavens and earth would never forget
about her and this is a bird that the
heavens and the earth is not created for
the bird the heavens and earth is
created for the human being so the human
being would never be forgotten but it's
the problem is in the human being they
put that they do not put their trust in
the creator of the heavens and the earth
they don't have a hymn in the sense that
Allah says in the Quran Allah attacked
Liholiho maharaja whereas Zuko in -
after whoever obeys Allah be dutiful to
him Allah will make ways out for that
purpose and he would for would provide
for him make ways out for that person
and would provide for him from ways that
he does not expect this is the words of
the creator of the heavens and earth and
never been proven to be wrong tell us
sheikh if someone feels that you know
what god almighty the creator allah he
loves me because I've got the Rolex I've
got the Mercedes and I keep rising in
status at my work so he feels blessed
now that the crater is blessing me and
he says you know what you still driving
a cab because you got the wrong belief
and the cratering giving you nothing
that's why your you know it's as a proof
that you're on the wrong way because
your
poor look at me I'm loaded I got the JC
go-cart I got the bank accounts full so
this person feels like this is the love
of his creator because he's just rolling
in abundance I'm gonna say about Allah
Spano Allah in the Quran corrected this
misunderstanding because it's present in
the human being in many verses one of
which it says over my lucuma who led to
come bility to has a book of antennas of
your wealth your families are not the
ones that would get you closer to Allah
Spano tada it's what your actions are
and he gave us the example of karoon the
cousin of Moses I'm not sure exactly
what's karun his name was in English but
he had so much wealth that the Quran
says that the keys for his treasures the
strongmen were not able to carry the
keys not the treasures the keys so
that's more than Bill Gates and Donald
Trump together it's amazing a lot of
money right and he says in the Quran
that he was boost for like this and he
says this is a signs that you know God
is pleased with me and he forgot about
his creator and so on then all of a
sudden in the blink of an eye I lost
panatela destroyed all of his worth and
while he was going out into the in front
of the people the weak ones would say we
wish that we have like what karoon has
right and then when everything is
finished you know they said we wish that
we know that the wisdom of allah
subhanaw taala and things so it does not
work by how much wealth that person has
because this is not the life that we
would live on it forever everything a
person will be asked about in the
Hereafter the real happiness there is
success the richness is when a person
entered the paradise that Allah created
for the videos and the real loss is what
a person is thrown into the our fight a
live never thought about the alarm a
said a statement which means there is no
goodness in a goodness that would lead
you to the fire and there is no evil in
an eva that would lead you to your
goodness but of course the obedience of
Allah is not evil but the point is if a
person is patient in the orders of Allah
that leads you to the everlasting
happiness that means this is the great
thing and that's why we do not promise
people anything of this dunya of this
world prophet saw solemn when he take
the pledges from the Companions he did
not tell them you'll have dimensions and
the palaces and all that he told them if
you believe in the creator of the
heavens and the earth he will give you
Jenna
and they accepted it and they submitted
themselves to a loss my natal when this
was their goal allah subhanaw taala
opened the treasures for them on this
earth and they became the rulers of the
land but not the goal to be like that
the goal is to seek the pleasure of the
creator of the heavens in you now you
have some people taking the means but
these means to acquiring wealth they
seem so tied up into the material world
that they're forgetting about some of
their obligations they feel like you
know what if I don't take the means then
I'm not going to make this money so they
will be missing the prayer late for the
prayer maybe not making the prayer at
all they might not be paying the charity
and it reminds me of a verse from the
verbatim word of God maybe if this is
interlinked at all and you can give us
the the explanation of it where the
Creator is saying that Shaitaan the
devil that he promises you poverty in
orders you to commit evil deeds Allah
promises you his forgiveness and his
great bounty okay how do you tie these
together and can you explain this this
is exactly what the deception of the
human being in if they do not follow the
revelation from Allah the verse says
that the Shaitaan as you said he
promises you poverty Shaitaan the devil
would never come to a person and tell
him or do this so that you become poor
yeah it's very clear yeah he promises
poverty by what by telling them to not
to give in charity not to give for the
sake of Allah and this is the net
selfish poverty because the butter had
the blessings of one's wealth we'd be
taken away and so he promises people
what they want to hear but in reality
this is the real poverty because a lost
panel Talas rules and laws are different
what the human beings are seeing under
their feet human being as if he's
looking under his feet and that's it if
he looks ahead you know he would see the
matter totally different and this is the
difference between the believers and the
non-believers allah subhanaw taala
out of his mercy he gave us these types
of rules on the face of earth you feel
allah useful to him you obey him he
would make ways out for you he would
provide for you who would understand
this not the disbelievers the believers
so they would take this as a mean with
the physical means so the time for the
salah comes and the person is about to
make a meal
Donna deal here but the call is from my
Creator the one that provides for me the
one that owns this million and owes
whatever that exists did you say a
million even billions thank you right he
would turn to the creator of the heavens
and the earth I don't knowing that he's
the provider he would provide for him
and he would bless his wealth for him
because he is the one that is owning
everything that is exists and that's
what I'm saying the two set of means
only the believers would understand it
and when there is conflict between both
they put forward the means that is
mentioned in the Quran and the Sunna of
the Prophet team I want to drive this
point home because you said blessed so
by doing establishing the prayer
worshiping your Creator alone trying to
abide everyday by what he's told you to
do then your life is blessed right but
on the other hand you don't have the
blessings if you're not praying if
you're not doing what he told you to do
right and the word blessings or Baraka
means that you have a goodness came to
you yeah money whatever health you know
everybody got gets there but the ones
that are blessed is when this goodness
stays with you yeah and brings goodness
for you and your heart is in a good
state and it stays with you but if you
get whole bunch and then you lose it all
of a sudden and then your heart does not
have that state of in which it will be
have this calmness in it
what is the goodness of what you have so
there's blessings in one's life you can
hit by something that you would lose
more and more money but I lost my note
Allah protect you as a result of you
being steadfast the religion of Islam
and this is something that people need
to understand it's not about just a
matter of one prayer here or there it's
the whole life economy politics
mannerism worship beliefs everything
there is a word of Allah that is order
from Allah so that the whole life of the
human beings will be accordingly
happiness in this life and in the years
a complete we align Pleet way of life
how can we get the people to see that
this is not something frivolous this is
not something trivial I mean their
importance because I come across a lot
of people that they feel that it's more
important to what there's nothing wrong
with getting a degree in school this is
encouraged but they feel like they will
sit through all the classes and get all
the credits so they can get this big
stat you know the degree finish but
when it comes down to the prayer let's
say this basic thing that you have to do
you just can't get them to do it for the
life of you because people are mixing
the means and the goals what is the goal
of our life you get the degrees you get
the wealth you get the highest level on
the face of earth then what when you go
to the grief you're not going to take
anything with that with you does that
mean that we need all of these things no
we do all of these things but it's only
a mean a reason for us to be holding
fast to our to the truth and and I
mentioned this hadith before the Prophet
SAW seldom said it to correct these
beliefs in us in the ends ll medula
komasan that the wealth has been
revealed to us so that we establish the
salaah so this is the main job of the
day you go to work so that adapte at the
time of the hora prayer you come to the
masjid and pray so that it helps you to
come pray because you need a way to get
to the message you need to eat and drink
and all of that is wealth so the goal is
the prayers the goal is the worship of
allah and everything else in our life is
to establish that goal and to make the
word of allah superiors tell us sheikh
we're almost at a time that you had
mentioned that you were listening to a
program and they were talking about the
economy and some people were feeling
that this isn't a time that people can
turn to their creator but then they
throw in Jesus in the mix of this right
what do we got to say how can we talk to
those people out there who feel like ok
they feel like they need to turn back to
their Creator but they turn on 7:50 a.m.
680 a.m. 455 fm whatever the case and
now they hear the creator but then mixed
in Jesus in the mix of all this right
how do we help clear this misconception
so clearly this misconception is who is
the provider the provider is the creator
of the heavens and earth the one that is
nothing is the like of him Jesus peace
be upon him one of the mighty messengers
of Allah Spano tell a human being that
Allah chose for the people to be to call
them to the creator of heavens and earth
would never provide for you any of what
Allah had created because he is a
creation of Allah and this is something
that Allah mentioned the community
Matadero name in dunya lammle kunio-kun
Blizzcon those who you call other than
Allah they they do not own any
provisions so
them they would never provide for you
but then instead called the creator of
the heavens and the earth he's the one
that will provide food the one Jesus
called the one that Jesus peace be upon
him he himself callin to the creator of
the heavens and yet that does not
belittle Jesus by the way this is
actually respect and honor Jesus more
and more because Jesus peace be upon him
he would never accept that somebody
would turn to him and not the creator of
the heavens and the earth and the
highest level that a human being can
reach is to be a servant of the creator
of the heavens and the earth and not to
be a creator himself or not to have the
attributes of the creator of the heavens
in you what about someone who might come
and he knows a little bit of the Bible
he says in the Bible it says that Jesus
said no one comes to the Father except
through me
what does that mean right regardless
whether this is true or not but the
messengers we cannot go to through the -
the Creator unless we go through the
messengers or knowing how to worship the
treat God the job of the messengers is
that they teach the people how to turn
to the creator alone how to make your
prayers how to put your trust in the
creator so nobody can ever be able to
turn to the Creator alone like this
without having the knowledge that the
messengers brought to the people not as
the physical barrier between them and
the creator of the heavens and earth so
it's it has to be understood they were
they were the teachers they were just
showing us how to get close to God but
did any of them ever say or call people
to worship themselves never and this is
something mentioned in the Quran there
is no evidence whatsoever whatsoever to
that every messenger called the people
to worship the creator of the heavens
and the earth and that would make or
should make sense to every human being
because the Creator is one so he's the
one that is worthy of worship and that's
it and that's the end of the story how
could someone were almost out of time
just how could someone who's has such an
emotional attachment they just kept
hearing the name Jesus's Jesus and you
got to go through Jesus to get to God
and you say in Jesus's name to get to
God and now they just they've been input
in this in their head just from a child
and then they go to the you know to the
to the prayer services and how does
someone now this what you're saying
actually makes sense worship God alone
how did they get away from this and
we're not calling anyone - not to
respect them to honor Jesus actually
becomes a disbeliever in the religion of
Allah
if you don't accept Jesus right we have
we accept Jesus peace be upon him you
have to love Jesus peace be upon him and
you have to admire him and so on and so
forth and there is verses and verses in
the Quran that talks about Jesus peace
be upon him but Jesus was a Messenger of
Allah you need to turn to the creator of
the heavens in the earth alone and you
won't deny Jesus you would still believe
in him you would believe in him and you
would love him and as a Messenger of
Allah and the final of all messengers is
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him and
he's the one that we followed the rules
that he brought and they're all brothers
as he said that he sought to serve all
the messengers or brothers and Allah
Sanatana is the one that sent them all
so don't worry you're not going to lose
Jesus peace be upon him in the sense
that you would deny him or disbelieve in
him no you would correct your belief in
him that he's a Messenger of Allah that
he is exalted and he is among the best
of the messengers of Allah as a result
of being a human being calling people to
the washability of the creator of the
heavens and the earth alone and by
believing in the rest at the final
message is it true that in the verbatim
word of God the Quran that is Jesus
mentioned peace be upon him more than
the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
that's true Jesus mentioned more than
many times actually in the Quran and it
shows also that of course Prophet
Mohammed Salim he's the best of all the
messengers of Allah but there are five
messengers of Allah these are all as in
with the best of all the messengers and
these are Noor and Abraham and Moses and
Jesus and Prophet Mohammad's fees be up
or the last and fun and the last and
finally is there a chapter named after
Jesus's mother in the crime yes there is
chapter called maryam or mary cat's
teeth and and and it also a call for
people to go read it yeah
we're not enforcing anything on anybody
go read it and think and see how the
stories in the quran that is the truth
that would make sense in Xalapa sure
thank you very much for being with us
again on the Deen show and thank you
again all praises to the creditor
heavens and earth do you see that we're
doing something very simple calling you
to something very simple you can have a
full bank account and all the money in
the world but just like many have lost
that much money it can go away just like
that but the one who is calling you to
something that is everlasting to the
paradise
is the crater of the hem is an earth
this is something that doesn't disappear
this is something that's forever and you
just have to commit yourself not to get
attached to the worldly things go out
and get a good job and take the means as
the Sheikh was telling you be the best
human being that you can be but attach
your heart to the next life the next
light that is forever and strive to see
the face of your Lord in paradise this
is something that we're all striving for
and we talked about Jesus and this was
something that I know is a little sensor
than some people but we love Jesus Jesus
was a mighty Messenger of God but he
never called people to worship himself
just like Moses never called people to
worship Him nor Abraham nor did Muhammad
peace be upon them all they were all
teachers teaching us how to get close to
God and if you liked what we had to say
here today come back again here on the
Dean show and we see you next time God
willing in sha allah until then assalamu
alaikum peace be unto you the DVDs for
Dawa as allah has said in the quran in
surah now 16 125 will do alasa be lit up
pick up the hikmah to invite all to the
way of your lord with wisdom beautiful
preaching and reason with them in ways
that are best and this is a great
opportunity for you to take up the
obligation take up the call as Allah has
told you to do and share this beautiful
message with the world Islam submission
to the one God come and see what
everyone's talking about you find one
contradiction it can't be from God but
the rational idea the rational
explanation is you do your best give up
for spring God is one I will never give
up spreading this message okay you take
that necessary step you don't know if
you're gonna live till tomorrow
so you got to find that urges you to do
the right thing right now if you say
that you do not believe in Jesus you
have stepped outside of his name you
cannot be a Muslim is that ended our
faith - it's cold it's lay everybody
sleeping I arise and ask a lot of
thinking me Omar you see all our you
know all the sins I do I turn to you to
forgive my sin tomorrow I'm using for
slave you don't my love in Lord I'm the
one runs away all the guide me